Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Star Wars
released a first look at the new Acolyte TV
show so we'll break it all down there's a brand
new hybrid public era series that they're working
on that'll be released next year so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos this is basically going
to be our Sith based Series in the Star Wars
Universe they're just obviously shifting to
a much earlier time period so this isn't set
During the period of the Mandalorian which is
five years after Return of the Jedi along with
the Ahsoka series that's a spin-off from the
Mandalorian as well as the new Skeleton Crew
series or any of the stuff they've been doing
inside the Imperial era between Revenge of
the Sith in A New Hope like I've been doing
the Andor videos for that series that takes
place before Rogue one we're almost done with
the episodes on that series I just got done
doing videos for Obi-Wan Kenobi episodes and
Darth Vader that set 10 years after the events
of Revenge of the Sith so we just haven't
done a lot of stuff before the events of
phantom menace myself included everybody's been
asking for a Knights of the Old Republic series
the acolyte is like the closest thing to that
because of where it takes place in the hybrid
public but just to explain the timeline when
the high Republic takes place relative to the
Old Republic Knights of the Old Republic stuff the
high Republic is everything before the events of
phantom menace to about 400 years ago I believe
the events of Star Wars acolyte will take place a
little bit closer to the events of phantom menace
just because I believe they're trying to set up
Darth Plagueis as well as Palpatine so we might
see like a very young version of Palpatine towards
the end of the series they've already announced
the main cast list we have a plot synopsis so I'll
explain what they actually said the plot is about
and who the main characters are and how they sort
of get involved with the Sith during the series
because they are upholding the Canon like they're
not going to break the rule of two or anything
like that I'll explain how that works as well
the official plot synopsis just reads the acolyte
is a mystery thriller that will take viewers to a
Galaxy of shadowy Secrets and emerging Dark Side
powers in the final days of the high Republic era
which is why I say it takes place closer to the
events of phantom menace a former Padawan reunites
with her Jedi Master to investigate a series
series of crimes but the forces they confront
are more Sinister than they ever anticipated so
it's sort of the idea of the Sith rearing their
heads again because up to the events of Revenge of
the Sith the emperor had kept the Sith relatively
quiet and under the radar the same was true of
his master Darth Plagueis and then all the way
back to Darth Bane that was all part of the rule
of two to stay under the radar so that the Jedi
wouldn't bother them so they're implying that at
least a couple of a Jedi will discover that the
Sith are alive and well and continuing to practice
and something bad will probably happen to them to
prevent them from telling someone like Master Yoda
for instance who's still very much alive and much
younger during this period in the timeline so you
think that the much younger version of Yoda would
be much quicker to jump on this Sith problem like
ah we got to take care of that right now nip it in
the bud it just means something is going to stop
those Jedi that Discover it from telling the truth
to the rest of the Jedi Council they announced
the main cast of the series and there are a couple
of big players in this too the main character is
being played by Amanda Stenberg and she's playing
someone called Aura she's the person that gets
tied up with this acolyte group of characters
trying to become Sith apprentices they announced
that Lee jong-jae from squid game is on the series
you actually see him in this first look picture
here it's him and the main actor Amanda Stenberg
talking to each other getting ready to film a
scene you know she's wearing a t-shirt from the
Mandalorian that's a Mandalorian t-shirt keeping
it in the Star Wars Family Manny Jacinto also
just joined the series you remember him from the
good place Daphne Keane who most people remember
from the Logan series Jody Turner Smith Rebecca
Henderson Charlie bartnett Dean Charles Chapman
who most of you remember is tommen from The Game
of Thrones series I did episode videos for all
those and they confirmed that Carrie Anne Moss
just joined the cast they didn't say who most
of them are playing the only one we really know a
lot about is the main character Amandla Stenberg
this Aura character supposedly the way that the
acolyte episode 1 is meant to pick up is that it
starts on a planet called sanchiro where she and
her sister are from is world mostly made up of
marshlands snowy mountains and this Aura character
and her sister her family live in a village
that's frequently attacked by a primitive tribal
beings they get attacked during the events of
episode 1 and they're fought off by the Jedi of
that period and because Aura is force sensitive
after that first attack they take Aura with them
for training but they leave her sister behind so
she's separated from her family very standard
practice for the Jedi to separate people from
their families all about attachments not good
thing everybody saw the prequels we know how that
went out for Anakin Skywalker that's why most the
time when Jedi are taken from their families it's
before they've been able to form attachments to
them like before they're old enough to actually
form memories that's why Obi-Wan Kenobi can barely
remember his own family he even talked about that
during the Obi-Wan Kenobi series like there's
an Obi-Wan Kenobi brother that's alive somewhere
in the Galaxy there's another Kenobi out there
somewhere but when the Jedi take Aura to start
her training The Villages attacked again the Jedi
are too late and her grandparents wind up getting
killed off and because her grandparents were
killed her sisters left alone she doesn't want
to leave her sister but the Jedi won't let her
take her sister with her are back to Coruscant
the Jedi Temple so you start to see the conflict
and the reason why she starts to hate the Jedi and
starts down the dark path to the Sith once she
starts down the dark path eventually she joins
a group of acolytes thus the title of the show a
group of dark side forced trainees that are trying
to become Sith apprentices and it sounds like
all these acolytes are forced to form a bunch
of Trials and fight each other and the winner
will become the next Sith apprentice and that's
their way of working within the Canon the rule of
two there must only ever be two officials Sith at
any given time but there are many Dark Side Force
users like you have this group of acolytes but
they're not traditional Sith you have to remember
the difference between Sith and just regular Dark
Side Force users the Sith were actually a race of
beings that intermingled with a bunch of dark side
Force users that kind of took over their culture
eventually what happened though is that there was
this great Jedi Sith War about a thousand years
ago Darth Bane wound up being the only member of
the Sith order to survive that he created the rule
of two to help the Sith persevere and thus it's
continued to present day long before that when the
dark side Force users took over the Sith culture
and started intermarrying intermingling with them
it was more of a traditional build up this giant
Sith Empire and then conquer the Galaxy kind of
thing where you have many many Sith practitioners
the whole idea going forward after Darth Bane is
that they would stay off the radar and thus the
Jedi wouldn't think of them as a threat or even
think about them at all but one of the things
they're going to do during the series is that it
won't just be like Breaking Bad in the Star Wars
Universe I mean it might be a little bit of that
is that they'll show you why some of the things
that the Jedi were teaching were bad like why
the Jedi Order became kind of stagnant George
Lucas has talked about this at length when he
was doing the prequel movies he wanted to show
that the Jedi Order had to change and even though
Anakin Skywalker was the child of Prophecy he was
meant to bring balance to the force the twist was
is that he needed to balance the light side as
well as the dark side like the light side had
become too powerful the Jedi Order had become
stagnant in two set in their ways thus the force
gives birth to Anakin Skywalker and he balances
things out the Hawaii with grogu's character
later during the events of the Mandalorian and
him rejecting Luke Skywalker in the Jedi Order is
their way of showing you that groku is rejecting
the old Jedi Order because that's kind of what's
going on with Luke Skywalker's Jedi Temple that's
the reason why it failed during the events of the
sequel movies because he started to make the same
mistakes as the old Jedi Order because he was
trying to teach the old hits basically like he
was trying to orchestrate his Jedi Temple and
his teachings the same way that the old Jedi
Order did like play the hits so the whole promise
with a grogu character much later in the timeline
and hopefully this will play out in future
series and future movies is that we'll see
grogu take the Jedi Order in a completely new
Direction that's completely different from the
Jedi that came before like Yoda but just remember
that grogu is only about 50 years old during the
events of the Mandalorian he's about the same age
as Anakin Skywalker which is why we have all those
theories about how there might be a twist with the
prophecy that the child of Prophecy might not just
be Anakin Skywalker it could also be grogu like
grogu will also bring balance to the force but
that just means that we might not see him during
the events of the acolyte series or if they do
use grogu or a young version of Anakin Skywalker
they'll just be easter eggs and references like
they'll just make references to the child of
Prophecy eventually coming to balance the force
like I said just based on what they've talked
about with the timeline of the series the closest
we get to like really big Easter egg characters
would be like very very young version of Palpatine
over here yeah tragedy of of Darth Plagueis the
whites we've been making the jokes about Palpatine
and his master Darth Plagueis for so many years
now Palpatine won't yet be old enough to become
Plagueis' apprentice at the end of the series
like this is meant to take place a little bit
before that so we might actually see Darth
Plagueis show up during the series and then
pay off some of his research into defying death
influencing the midichlorians to either create
or extend life that was the whole tale that he
was telling to Anakin Skywalker he was basically
trying to explain to him in so many words how
he essentially learned how to influence the
midichlorians in thus Master life and death and
then kill his master like that's the whole idea
is that there are only ever two Sith at any given
time and usually The Apprentice winds up killing
the master and that's how you become a Sith master
so that also might be one of the big twists of the
series is that when the main character becomes a
Sith Apprentice eventually she will kill whoever
the master winds up being and because this
is mostly a Sith bass series I don't know how
much time we're going to spend on Coruscant
with other people like the younger Yoda and
the other Jedi drawings that era I believe it's
supposed to be about 8 Episodes but I think we'll
hear more about that soon based on their filming
schedule it sounds like they're going to try and
Premiere it towards the end of next year unless
there's some big delay or some big issue while
they are working on it of course I'll do episode
videos for it as soon as it premieres but as any
other big questions you have about the series or
what they're going to cover or big Easter eggs
or backstory just write it below in the comments
and a lot to my future bonus videos because we're
almost done with the Star Wars and or episodes
we'll probably get a new Mandalorian season 3
trailer really soon too big reminder that next
year we're gonna have the Mandalorian season 3
episodes and then after that we'll have the Ahsoka
episodes and then obviously like I said probably
the acolyte episodes so a whole bunch of Star
Wars coming next year everyone click here for my
Mandalorian season 3 trailer video and click here
for my brand new black panther wakanda forever
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!